bounty hunting is a complicated  profession  this being the case a man of your skill  should make short work of this  what it is i don't know  but what it does  this i've heard rumors happen i have  spoken  any idea what they're gonna do with it  the kid's coming with me better chance  at a life  i'm gonna need help i'm in they all hate  you  bando  because you're a legend  my creed you are as its father  who's he checking the child then they'll  keep coming  you have something i want  it means more to me than you will ever  know  it will be mine  come on baby do the magic hand thing  you must reunite it with its own kind  you expect me to search the galaxy for  the home of this creature  this is the way  you